my dad
natalia bryant is opening up about the
influence her late father kobe bryant
continues to have on her as a parent we
want our kids to learn in a rare
interview with img models the stunning
18 year old reflects on special memories
with her dad and how it's shaping her
future
probably my dad so my dad and i would
always watch like as many movies as we
can and we'd go on like movie marathons
and then we'd also like analyze as many
movies as we can and we'd like talk
about it for months anywhere we go we
just keep talking about like different
films and how like it reminds us of like
where we are oh my gosh like that
architecture reminds me of like this
piece from like this film so it's just
things like that it just really inspired
me and i was like i want to do this like
forever natalia also credits her dad for
the most daring thing she's ever done
swimming with sharks my dad convinced me
but this one was really little so i
asked him like are they my shirts and
he's like yeah they're that one's really
nice it's like okay cool and they're all
like black tips and like white tip
sharks but at least i can say i did it
she later shares that in 10 years she
wants to follow in kobe's footsteps and
win an oscar i'm not sure for what or
what
oscar category but i definitely think
that's on my list and i definitely i
want to make a film
that's like where i can incorporate
fashion in like those fashion aspects
and i think like combining like my two
passions like that's just amazing
i want to be able to do that the nba
star won an oscar in 2018 for best
animated short film for dear basketball
i did everything for you
because that's what you do when someone
makes you feel as alive as you've made
me feel
like gianna when the nominations came
out
you know i she told me she said see that
hard work makes the dream work
in march shortly after natalya signed
with the model agency her mom vanessa
revealed how kobe would feel about their
eldest daughter pursuing her modeling
dreams she wrote on instagram daddy
would be so happy that you're pursuing
your modeling career now that you're 18.
you're beautiful inside and out
beautiful with makeup and without makeup
we love you
[Music]
probably my mom
i
probably take
the most style tips from my mom other
fun facts natalia is a huge fan of the
movie mamma mia and taylor swift i just
love how she's always she's very
positive but she also empowers young
girls and she empowers women
i just think that's so important in life
and she's always been like one of my
biggest role models it's been a year of
milestone achievements for the 18 year
old model who got accepted to her dream
school the university of southern
california okay when i first got into
usc i absolutely i was over the moon i
was freaking out the whole day leading
up to the where i had to click the
button to see if i got in or not i
couldn't eat if i get really freaked out
or something i just don't have an
appetite my first meal was probably
dinner and once i finally got in i like
probably cried for an hour after as soon
as i clicked the button i didn't read it
and there's confetti so i was like oh my
god i got it i told my mom i got it
vanessa recently dropped natalia off at
school and shared it was an emotional
experience writing today was rough this
was before the tears came down vanessa
captioned the post missing peace forever
i love you natalia bryant be epic and
fight on